Fighting pollution is just one of the many
items on the agenda at the climate change
conference in Katowice.
But for many countries the price of confronting
global warming is steep.
Just the fact that Poland is hosting this
gathering has been slammed by environmental
groups - because of its dependence on coal.
The Polish president dismissed the critics."Using
one's own natural resources, in Poland's case
coal, and basing energy security on them does
not conflict with climate protection and with
progress on climate change.
The UN begs to differ.
It says greenhouse gas levels are again at
a record high worldwide.
If that trend continues, temperatures could
rise by 3 to 5 degrees Celsius this century.
Extreme weather ranging from hurricanes to
droughts, flooding and wild fires would become
the norm, not an exception.
Even as we witness devastating climate impacts
causing havoc across the world, we are still
not doing enough, nor moving fast enough,
to prevent irreversible and catastrophic climate
disruption."
The US has said it is planning to withdraw
from the Paris climate accord.
But many American states and cities are deeply
committed to the pact.
They even brought their big guns to Poland
like former California governor Arnold Schwarzenegger
to try and show - they'd like to be back
I wish I could be the terminator - in real
life.